now what do you got going on there's a
guy in staten island
who he's not like i'm watching this guy
on tv
and i mean no disrespect but he's not a
tv guy he's not a public figure had a
person is a regular guy
and so he's not giving you that polished
politician answer they're like why are
you
opening your bar and defying these
lockdowns and he's just like
we got to do something like they're
they're destroying us it's like we have
nothing left
and they pointed something out it's
really crazy the staten island story
they said this bar where the guy defied
the police
the police line up and block the
entrance these cops are nuts they were
like two blocks away
everything's normal restaurants dining
totally normal
what happens is de blasio just decides
this is a red zone and they put on the
ground
with like it's like paint or something a
sign saying danger zone or something
it's the creepiest thing
just segmenting off parts of the city
saying your business is done
it's it's it feels like mafioso
like what their goal is hey uh my name
is bill de blasio cuomo come over here
we're going to shut down this part of
the city so that all the
all the property value collapses buy it
up he said he was going to do it bill de
blasio said he was going to do it i have
to say uh bill de blasio really loves to
graffiti the streets in europe
of new york city he seems to really have
a knack for that
and it's just absolutely insane like you
won't be able to walk down to another
street or another block or another
neighborhood
the new york city subway system is still
open and operating and in many instances
crowded with a large number of
individuals when you see
you know you know the como brothers when
you see the politicians
when you see them defying their own kind
of rules and decrees
like if you want people to take you
seriously you should take
what policies you're proposing what
policies or decrees you're pushing on
people you should follow them
as well and they're not they're openly
celebrating
biden's victory they're openly promoting
black lives matter protest because black
lives matter protests are
essential and way more important than
the conhole sickness
uh and it's absolutely ridiculous that's
that's listen yeah
this is why i think we i i you know i
used to say like man we're about to go
over the edge huh
i think we went over the edge a long
time ago we were falling for a long time
we hit the ground like there's no going
back from this
for a year now we've seen democrats
flaunt their own rules
they they they say oh no we got to do
all these things and then they go to the
opposite nancy pelosi gets her hair it
gets her hair done gretchen whitmer lori
lightfoot
then they do the lockdown again saying
things are getting so bad we gotta lock
everything down and then knew some goes
in parties with a bunch of doctors
in a closed room and then he's like that
was a mistake then all of these
democrats are flying to hawaii for
vacation
they're laughing in the faces of those
and they're destroying the lives of
working-class people
and where is antifa nowhere to be found
they were screaming that there was a guy
with an orange face and then as soon as
the orange guy leaves they're like okay
we're fine with the fascism now bye
yeah cnn goes after people who make
memes that are
against them and doxes them meanwhile
when you see a legitimate threat against
the livelihood of individuals this poor
guy he's trying to
make ends meet he's trying to make a
living he's trying to make sure his
employees
have a paycheck so they they could
actually eat they could actually live
in one of the most taxed regulated
controlled cities in
all of the united states and you after
buying by all the laws after doing
everything you're supposed to do this
guy also had
a pretty good idea i have to say he
declared his business in
autonomous zone just like chaz and he
says well this is an autonomous zone
because
again when chaz first started this was
nothing that
was questioned nothing that was stopped
by the authorities
nothing that was uh you know brought up
as a health hazard of individuals
camping together
staying together in close quarters
without proper
bathroom facilities no one even talked
about that but you open up a business
where you want to make a living for
yourself and
this is the first of its case that i saw
here in the united states where it
actually led to an arrest
right this happened recently in toronto
what happened in jersey
uh well people the gym owners yes the
gym owners were
there was the salon owners arrested yes
yes i remember even uh you know
that was i was i was at that gym i was
talking to the main gym owner of
a friend was actually uh grew up grew up
with him
uh and was a was a high school friend of
him and
what what happened to them and what
happens to individuals it's mainly
individuals who are standing up
and they're raising their voice about
how insane how unjust how
unscientific how illogical a lot of this
is
and because of that they get targets on
their back and the government sends out
police officers who don't question
anything who many times follow decrees
these are not laws right there's not
even even debates these are not even
laws that are codified there's no it's
just him ordering his praetorian guard
to go abuse the the
peasants yeah not based off science i
mean if you really do
care about our personal well-being you
know maybe we could have a conversation
about proper health
proper sleep proper diet proper exercise
making sure that we're not stressed out
gun safety training
mandatory gun ownership yeah universal
universal gun program
where the government has mandated to
give everyone a gun i like that idea
from the gun
the department of gun services dude
diet's huge obesity's
insane epidemic high fructose corn
syrups just insidious the way that
they're
injecting this stuff into our population
let me ask you though you're from new
york right
i moved from new york this year and i
moved and i moved up to the
live free or die state new hampshire has
been an incredible experience let me ask
you uh do the police in new york swear
notes the constitution
um i'm not sure if they do but the cops
do that
um there's this duty to serve and
protect but legally the new york city
police
department argued in court many times
that they have no duty
to uh to protect you to help you
or to do anything to you or for you and
this was exemplified by my friend
joe lozito that literally took down
a mass murderer there was a mass
murderer on the loose police officers
saw that this mass murderer was on the
loose they were inside of a train car
watching as joe lozito was being stabbed
joel
watched yeah i met joe lozito you know
through a friend
i became friends with him and he told me
this story i saw the scars on his head
randomly at a bar
and i'm like my goodness like i i need
to share your story
and uh yeah i mean he had a butcher
knife
stabbed in the head almost lost his life
bled out everywhere
after taking down the killer joe luzito
took down the killer
badly injured police officers only after
he was taken down
came out of that subway car and then
they uh handcuffed
you know the criminal and they waited
and they and they even
derailed uh the the train from moving
because of official protocol which made
joe lozito bleed out he woke up in the
hospital
with mayor i think it was bloomberg at
the time congratulating these two
officers
that stood back as heroes who took down
a murderer and they called him a victim
he sued the city the city argued we had
no duty to protect you as you were
getting stabbed as we had guns
and clubs and could have stopped this
man almost killing you we didn't have to
so what you're saying
is defund the police
i mean again there's other examples we
could talk about
such as charon that i personally
traveled to which are these autonomous
kind of uh zones where there are no
police where there are no governments i
think
there is everyone's got guns security
well they live
in their own uh land
thirty thousand people in tehran where
they
decide what they're going to mexico
themselves yes it's in michioacan it's
in one of the deadliest states of all of
mexico
that is reporting no debts after
the population rose up with small arms
with pitchforks with knives and
throughout
the cartel the police department and the
government that were all working
in tandem and now they're living more
prosperous than ever there hasn't been a
murder in that town
for i think seven years now i did a full
documentary
traveling down there 30 000 people uh
yes they're armed you don't have their
own guns of course here's people don't
get
what's the point of an occupation a
military occupation you want people to
give you something you want to control
the land for some strategic resource
or you want the people to give you a
portion of their labor and resources
you want stuff you want it from them
what happens if they all
say no then occupation gets you nothing
what can you do if the people won't give
you what you want
so it's not even about small arms it's
about just defiance
at a certain point you're like it costs
me more trying to get these defiant
people
to do anything they won't do these
people on the left they don't realize
when they talk about
you know insurrection and revolution
civil war whatever the second amendment
that's meaningless because the
government has you know cruise missiles
and it's like bro read your history i'm
laughing in vietnamese yeah yeah
yeah yeah right tunnels that's what the
vietnamese did
giants it's just about having people say
no say no
look right now if everybody in staten
island nah
what are they gonna do the cops are
gonna be like we can't do anything yeah
that's it they have to bring in these
cops from outside these areas to enforce
this stuff too because
they'd be like their their aunt would
come out with a you know rolling pin and
being like what you doing get out of
here you know
so they bring in guys from other parts
of the city and they move them down and
they have them enforce laws that nobody
nobody wants and it's crazy to me that
even though you have this guy in staten
island he defies this
they're all still doing everything by
the appropriate cdc guidelines
they're just not shutting their doors
and then the cops come out
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time